China is already a giant.
This country is the largest trading power
in the world
They lead the world with hundreds of products
and have one of the largest foreign currency
reserves on the entire planet.
Not even the “petromonachies” in the Persian
Gulf can compete with this giant.
And with all of this, it isn't surprising
to find some analysts who state that China
will pass the United States as the leading
economic power…
But with a lot more inhabitants!
However, we usually forget a very important
thing, and this is that GDP is not everything,
and economic power, the real power, is closely
related to corporate power and, when it comes
to that, China is still far from reaching
the level of the United States.
If we look at the top 100 largest companies
in the world, 56 are American, and only 11
are Chinese.
And this is something to really bear in mind
because multinationals are in control of foreign
investment and of 80% of the world’s exports.
Now, the big question is what is going to
happen to these Chinese companies in the future?
How are things changing?
And what can we expect?
These are some of the questions we are going
to answer in today’s video!
The Chinese Giant’s Development
The Chinese economy has had an impressive
growth rate in the last three decades, and
the key was the concept of: “The World’s
Factory”.
That is what China is known for.
They are known as a country that has become
a world power and has lifted hundreds of thousands
people from poverty with a relatively simple
premise: producing everything, and produce
it at a low cost.
Toys, electronics, tools, clothing…
when you enter a store you are going to find
hundreds of products with something in common:
they are all manufactured in massive industrial
areas located all over China.
However, in order for a country to really
be the leading economic power, these companies
need to start producing much more complex
products, and they will have to stop competing
on cost and start looking for higher added
value.
This can include the production of things
like capital assets, planes, medical devices,
and computer processors.
And today, all these sectors are dominated
by the large multinationals of the United
States, South Korea, Europe, and Japan.
It is true, that many leading products are
manufactured in China, like the iPhone for
example, but… this is not exactly true,
because what China actually does is just the
assembly.
What this means is that the more complex parts
are bought from other countries and then they
are simply put together in China.
To better illustrate this consider that:
Each year, China imports more than 200 billion
dollars in semiconductors, which are essential
in the manufacturing of mobile devices.
Just as a comparison, that is more money than
what the country spends on petrol!
However, Chinese companies have made many
advances…
Today, a fourth of all exports are of capital
assets, such as machines, for example, or
high tech products.
In some sectors like telecommunications, wind
turbines, or high speed trains, Chinese companies
are the world leaders.
And it is not just that, Chinese companies
are learning how to make it in the international
market.
The Great Chinese Conquest
2016 was the 40th anniversary of the end of
the cultural revolution: this was a terrifying
campaign which Mao organized in order to purify
the revolution and finish off all remnants
of capitalism in Chinese society.
Well, since then, things have changed a lot…
So much that China is only behind the United
States in terms of numbers of multinational
companies.
Companies in this country are starting to
make it to global markets… and, well, they
are doing it really well!
In 2016, Chinese companies spent the amazing
amount of 225 billion dollars in the purchase
of foreign companies.
In Europe and the United States alone they
bought out more than 450 companies.
These Chinese companies are buying all kinds
of businesses: mining companies, banks, oil
companies, pharmaceutical companies, agricultural
companies, even luxury hotel chains, jewelry
companies and football clubs.
Yep, you heard it right, the Chinese, dear
viewer, have even bought Inter Milan, and
that is just one example.
“Manchester City gets $400 million Chinese
investment deal”
But, if there is one thing in particular that
the Chinese like to invest in, well that would
be developing countries.
Even though Australia and the United States
are the two main countries where the Chinese
money is invested, more than half of all Chinese
investment is made in emerging countries in
Asia, Africa, Latin America and the Middle
East.
So, we could almost say that, the more risky
the country, the more willing the Chinese
are to invest.
Now this might surprise you, but this isn’t
the end of the story…
Chinese companies are also starting to compete
hard.
Want some proof of this?
Well, if there was only one Chinese company
in the top 100 most valuable companies in
2006, there were 14 by the year 2015.
Take a look at the smartphone industry alone.
Up until recently, having a Chinese phone
was a bit…
weird...
right?
Well, today, the four main Chinese manufacturers:
Oppo, Huawei, Vivo and Xiaomi aren't just
more famous than they were a few years ago,
they also take more than 10% of the world’s
profits in this industry... and this is a
figure that is growing more and more every
year.
How about another example?
Lenovo, a Chinese multinational that was born
just a few years ago, bought the laptop division
of IBM, and is now the largest computer company
in the world, and they even supply equipment
to the Pentagon!
And want even more examples?
There’s Haier, the biggest manufacturer
of household appliances; or Cofco, a company
that’s acquiring land all over the world,
like sugar cane plantations in Australia,
French vineyards or soy plantations in Brazil.
There is also Geely, a car company which became
of international note when it bought out Volvo
in 2010.
Yep, Volvo, that legendary Swedish car brand
is now property of the Chinese…
But, if there is a sector where China is really
getting ahead, it is , against all odds, the
internet.
And I say against all odds because, as you
all know, the Chinese net is subject to complete
control and censorship by the Chinese government
with something known as “The Great Firewall”,
which blocks access to Facebook, Google, and
the Economist, to name just three.
However, in China it’s pretty normal to
do everything through apps.
For example, when you visit China you rarely
pay with credit cards, the most common thing
is to pay with a mobile phone using the app
Wechat - this is a “super-app” that is
like an all-in-one: Facebook, Paypal, Gmail,
Twitter etc…
By the way, Wechat is property of Tencent,
one of the top 15 most valuable companies
in the world, which is also the world’s
largest supplier of online games, and one
of the majority shareholders of Tesla.
So, by now, you are probably realising that,
yep, the Chinese are everywhere.
As for another example of their success,
consider Alibaba, an e-commerce company that
brings in $450 billion every year.
Not bad right?
And in China alone they have 400 million clients.
As Napoleon said:
“Let China sleep, for when she wakes she
will shake the world”
But before we all get scared, think about
what it all means: more competition, better
prices, better products, and faster technological
development…
As consumers we can benefit a great deal from
this transition.
Now, it obviously has plenty of risks too…or
at least this is what US intelligence agencies
are warning.
“According to the House Permanent Select
Committee on Intelligence’s report, Chinese
companies cannot be trusted to be free of
foreign state influence and thus pose a security
threat to the United States and to our systems”
And then there is the risk for companies,
they will have even much more competition…
although many more opportunities too, which
we previously discussed in the video we are
linking to on the screen now!
But, let’s not get too ahead of ourselves…
Chinese companies are still far behind in
technological terms, and they are in debt,
and a lot of it…
“China's corporate debt levels are too high
but it will take time to bring them down to
more manageable levels” Zhou Xiaochuan,
Head of the Central Bank of China.
And that is not the end of it, don’t forget
that China is a dictatorship, and this means
that the government has too much power when
it comes to corporate decisions.
Further the government is rather arbitrary
and unpredictable.
For example, a few years ago the government
encouraged Chinese companies to try the
international market and they would loan them
as much money as they needed to do so, but
now they have decided they want the opposite…
If a Chinese company wants to buy out a foreign
company, they need the approval of the Chinese
Communist Party and there are new tough limitations
on money leaving the country.
Further to that we have to add censorship,
legal uncertainty, trade obstacles, the bad
reputation of Chinese products… and so on
and so forth.
So, we can say that right now the United States’
position as leader is not in particular danger,
unless something changes that is more dramatic
than what we are currently seeing.
Long term though…
well who knows…
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe if you haven’t already, brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday.
And don’t forget to check out the Reconsider
Media podcasts - they provided the vocals
in this episode that aren’t mine.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.